[Music]
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen my
name is a Mogan barker I have here with
me also balaji krishna my colleague and
as we are set in a movie theater we will
walk you through a movie of SA peas data
management journey also how we are
trying to bring best of both worlds from
ACP and Google and in an offering to to
you so brief agenda how we are gonna
walk you through in terms of what do we
see from the enterprise data landscapes
what is ACP data hub the product that we
are going to walk you through how we are
working and collaborating with Google
cloud and a few customer examples and of
course we want to keep it interactive or
also I have questions from you guys so
let's go through as you can see here is
the kind of evolution in terms of the
enterprise intelligence on one axis as
towards the data diversity on the other
one you all know that we have seen more
OLTP as a start where the transaction
processing was the first step into the
enterprise world via this ap started our
journey also from there onwards then we
saw a push and move towards enterprise
bi or reporting and that's when the OLAP
world came into being and as we are
moving more and more towards
heterogeneous landscapes and more
diverse data we are seeing a multi
faceted data management requirement we
are seeing also technologies like
machine learning ai ai ot being used as
well and that is where it becomes now
more and more interesting how we can
address all these kind of data
management challenges also in the future
just to bring a little context as to why
and how data is changing the world here
is an example where
last year judge gave a ruling in Ohio
that the data from a pacemaker could be
used against an investigation four-inch
fire insurance investigation you all
might have seen that how one father had
reached out to the marketing dream from
Target when they were sending some
commercials related to pregnancy and
later he found out that they were
actually not wrong their predictions
were true and they knew more or had more
data points on his household in terms of
movies we have seen that the data
science teams have been collecting more
and more data just like in this kind of
a setup when it gets exciting or when it
is scary and try to see that which
scenes are creating what effect and
bring that into action for their next
productions also from Spotify we have
seen that they are using it to bring out
more ad business we have seen also that
after breaks it they sent out these kind
of ads and you know it's end of the
world kind of a thing or what you see on
screen about Valentine's Day and of
course in Japan the land where there are
a lot of earthquakes we have seen as
well that even apps on the iPhone are
being used to to gather data and then
try to predict as to what can be done or
what is the kind of intensity that is
happening but now coming towards a
little bit in terms of the corporate
world as well what we are seeing is a
picture like this there are a lot of
silos data is separated and what we see
also is with mergers and acquisition
scenarios coming in it adds to to
another challenge and further it up now
with the kind of open source world or
big data and hadoop scenarios it adds a
further complexity to this and it
becomes really
a big challenge for the teams to see
that how they can avoid duplication of
data how they can avoid unnecessary
movement of data and go through bringing
all these silos together for a single
version of truth what we are seeing is
also an explosion just to give you a
context in the last 5,000 years the
amount of data that was created which we
already exceeded in the last you know
2016-2017 years and it's predicted by
2025 it will become humongous it is
expected to be 163 zettabytes of data so
manually actually analyzing this data is
simply out of the question
that's where we want to automate as much
as possible and bring value from the
data to make sense and have intelligent
insights so when this volume of data
comes in understanding that data or
finding patterns and so on is also
equally important what do you see on
screen here is you know some picture
where you can add context you can add
some water and you can see that maybe
it's a it's a seagull when you build
some context around that data and add
some meaning to that but at the same
time if you add a different context then
you are able to see a different picture
and bring out a different meaning from
that of course a skilled veterinarian
can differentiate between this and that
is the kind of a job the data management
data governance data science kind of
roles are today facing and with this
what we try to do from a say P side is
we got feedback from some of the
customers as well as from some analysts
and with the study also from KPMG we
realized that there are at least of five
principles if you think from data side
there is data visibility almost 3/4 of
the customers said
yes this is definitely complex and that
limits their agility data quality is a
big concern most of the CEOs are saying
that okay this is where we are basing
our decisions on and for innovation they
are saying that they're not getting most
out of the data also in terms of if you
ask them that are you know are you
knowing how much data is relevant for
your decisions they are not even able to
give rough percentages this is a big big
problem that we sense and where we could
bring out some offerings TCO is a factor
compliance we had GDP are coming in
Europe we have californication so all
these things will will definitely shape
up in terms of the challenges for our
customers
that's where ASAP came out with a
different kind of a thought process and
we wanted to now see how we can address
all these challenges together how can we
build a kind of 360 view to to give them
a view across their enterprise data
which means that it can be enterprise
also the open source world how can we
seamlessly integrate data quality
capabilities in there how can we give
them also all the tools that are
available today to drive their
innovation initiatives in a very agile
manner at the same time we wanted to
avoid the data redundancy we wanted to
avoid the high cost of data so we wanted
to to optimize that by decentralized
data processing as well and of course in
the end too to give them the confidence
and get them to be compliant with their
data sets so what ACP has come out with
its new offering we launched late last
year ACP data hub we are trying to help
our customers become more and more
data-driven what you see here on on the
left hand side is the SI p world with
ACP HANA
as the core of the digital platform and
we have on the other side the open
source world we are trying to help now
everyone right from data discovery in
terms of metadata governance with the
orchestration with very kind of agile
data pipelining capabilities you will
see it in also and demo later and at the
same time we are trying to expand the
reach into the connectivity and also get
out the reach into the cloud
infrastructure providers Google is a
very close partner so we are working
with Google cloud team as well in terms
of a architecture view here is what you
see we are on the layer below addressing
all the data storages it can be
on-premise it can be in a Hadoop store
it can be in the Rost or it can be in a
cloud store as well and on top of that
you will have the runtime from a CP data
that is where we are also using
kubernetes you heard a lot from Diane
green today about kubernetes and soon
there as well to see how we are then
seamlessly integrating that to give you
the means to to have that elasticity as
well and then we are trying to connect
it into also all the ASAP applications
as as we go on as well as we are giving
you rest api is to connect in if you
want to connect to any other application
as well on top then you are seeing how
we are trying to bring in capabilities
towards metadata cataloging towards data
discovery how we can have a one-stop
shop to also more monitor schedule and
get all the landscape administration and
you will see also in the demo how easily
you can bring and build data pipelines
and define Wow and where the data should
flow in terms of
for example with the flow based big data
management here is how you can see there
can be multiple sources when comes in
the heterogeneity you can have data
which is raw data but it is now
increasingly becoming important for your
enterprise decisions you can bring in
that stream data in you can combine it
with your master data you can have your
data provisioning done in a distributed
environment and to do all this you are
starting from ingestion or collection of
the data then you want to refine the
data bring in the structure especially
for the raw data make a model and then
bring it out for for consumption and
then when you deploy that you can
automate that you can reuse that it's
very easy to to get in there and without
further ado I would like to then bring
in Balaji who can talk a little bit in
terms of also what we are doing in the
hybrid cloud and walk it through a demo
thank you I just want to make sure okay
perfect though I just want to make sure
the mic is on so continuing from where a
Moog left off we're seeing this rise of
hybrid cloud obviously when you heard
the keynote this morning like one of the
speaker's was mentioning 8 out of 10
customers still look at a multi cloud
and hybrid environment where a lot of
assets are on Prem but they're gradually
migrating over to the cloud and we see
this happening across different cloud
environments primarily GCP and Google
being one of the main partners for SA P
in this journey and as part of this
journey what we've realized as the main
advantage for a lot of customers when
migrating to the cloud is how easily
they can migrate the workloads without
having to worry about the whole DevOps
aspect of it so it's moving from a
DevOps to no operational kind of
experience and that's what is enabling a
lot of our customers and sa P is a
company which has been in this service
for around 46 years so we have a lot of
customers who still have on Prem but
we still see that there is a gradual
migration from our existing customer
base to a cloud kind of environment
obviously a lot of new customers that we
are grading are primarily cloud only but
there are a lot of on-prem customers and
for them we provide this choice
especially when trying to manage their
data more efficiently when the data is
spread across cloud on-prem and multi
cloud environments and what we try to
provide is this capability of best of
both worlds because again putting the
emphasis on here I still have my ERP
system which I'm in the process of
upgrading migrating from ECC system is
AP ERP system to s4 cloud which is our
digital code but in the interim I want
to be able to bring in the data that is
on Prem and also combine with other
applications which are running on the
cloud whether it is s AP conquer or
simply successfactors which is cloud
native applications that sa P has so how
do I bring in the data which is sitting
in all these different layers and make
some sense out of it make insights and
that's where data hub provides this
capability on how we can leverage data
hub to build these pipelines and beyond
that also talk to big data systems or
data lakes where when you're doing
something like a data lineage or impact
analysis it's not enough if you're just
looking at your traditional relational
data which is primarily data at rest but
you also want to look at the data in
motion which could be data coming from
IOT stream it could be coming from web
blogs it could be social media data so
how do I bring that lineage across my
different artifacts starting from a bi
dashboard or analytics report that I'm
looking at and tried to point that to a
source of origin which could be hey this
data came from s AP ERP system but now
it is residing in HDFS file as a park'
format so it's very important for us to
combine these two worlds which is the
on-prem and the cloud and especially
when we talk about these multi cloud
environments and support different kinds
of workloads like I said it could be the
IOT streaming workloads or it could be
advanced analytics which is now migrate
to the whole machine learning a I kind
of workloads and finally our basic cloud
storage where I'm looking at a data
aging data tearing strategy where I want
to push my cold data into a cloud or a
frozen state so how do I ensure that I
build a pipeline which you can also
bring in the data from a frozen state
combine that with hot data in memory
data that we have in SA P Hana which is
our central core of the digital platform
so we have collaborated with Google on
multiple aspects but one of the primary
things here is how do we leverage gke
primarily the kubernetes engine but
beyond that gke and that's where we have
a lot of customers who are running
kubernetes on Prem whether it's through
support from Red Hat or so say but it
was interesting to hear this morning at
the keynote that now we'll have gke on
Prem as well so a lot of our customers
are going to be excited because they're
already on the journey to using gke and
for us we've been working with
kubernetes for almost two years now
and even before the 0.1 release was made
available so we've gone through the ups
and downs and it's interesting to see
the adoption in terms of how kubernetes
is being adopted not just across the
customers but also across other partner
landscapes so for us it's important that
we ensure that this kubernetes allows us
to build more and more as we deliver
data hub as a service in the future
where today it's available as
infrastructure to the service but we are
looking at a managed service where you
can come in and you can buy the compute
hours and you just need this compute to
build a pipeline which does the
cleansing and refinery tasks for a data
scientist for them to run their data
scientist workloads and as you've heard
in several talks especially when we talk
about ml and AI and data science almost
70% of those tasks are related to I want
to ensure that I've cleaned the data
I've cleansed the data I have the right
kind of data before I can actually hand
it over to my data scientist so data
scientists
are also working as data engineers and
with a tool like data hub we simplified
that capability for a data scientist for
him or her to go in and build those
specific data scientist workflows which
is one of the use cases a MOOC is going
to be talking about in the future and
one of the next slides I also want to
bring out this partnership that we're
doing with Google Google and Cisco and I
think you heard some of these again at
the keynote sa P has been working as one
of these triangular partners in this
initiative for almost a year now and
it's great to see that we already have
our first version of the customers who
are looking at this and they're already
gaining a lot of benefits in terms of
enabling gke along with Google Cloud as
a hybrid cloud running on Cisco platform
so this is really great for us to share
this information with our customers in
terms of data hub being one of the first
applications from sa P which is able to
take advantage of this partnership
between Cisco and Google and finally
before I go to the demo I just want to
kind of set the stage for the demo that
we're going to be talking about today
primarily this is again a collaboration
for one of our customers that we did
between Google and sa P where we are
taking in the data from point of sales
information so we have point of sales
data that is being streamed in through
Google cloud platform primary
specifically a pops up the output of
that Google pops up is being returned
into Google bigquery and again this
pipeline is being managed using data hub
and the Google bigquery data is being
consumed in SA P Hana as a data
virtualization layer this is where we
talk about Hana as being that broader
information fabric or in-memory fabric
or the logical data warehouse where what
we are enabling from data hub is leave
your data wherever it is whether it's in
your Google cluster or your on-prem we
allow you to do the push downs to
wherever the data is so that you do the
heavy lifting where the
and then we bring it do the joints that
are required before we can make that
available for visualization through your
favorite bi tool or - boring tool so let
me switch to the demo before I can hand
it over to a moke for the use cases so
what you're seeing here before that
actually I wanted to show the bigquery
demo first before we go into so what we
are seeing here is a big data analytics
demo partnership between data hub and
bigquery so as I mentioned earlier we
are streaming data from point-of-sales
across the different retail stores in US
and this data is being streamed through
a pubsub and data hub is used as a
configuration management for connecting
this pub/sub and for streaming the data
oh you're not able to see sorry about
that
Thank You MOOC okay so this is the
architecture diagram that I showed
earlier and primarily what we're doing
here is we're leveraging data hub and
this is the data hub pipeline modeler so
here what you see is I am reading the
data from Google storage and I'm
streaming the data into a Google pub/sub
and the output of that pops up is being
consumed into a big Google bigquery
which in term is being accessed through
a Hana calculation view so for folks who
familiar with sa P Hana and the Hana
data modeling you're familiar with
calculation views so we consume this
data as part of a calc you and then
expose that through a visualization
using a simple analytics cloud so here
I'm looking at the configuration for my
file so here I'm using a CSV file and
the CSV file is in route path SAPT ADA
hub now I switch to my Google GCSE and
I'm just pointing to the location where
I have my source file that I'll be using
for this demo exercise and of the next
step I'm going to point to the Google
pub/sub and the sink where I have
mentioned the information so the topic
where I'm capturing this information in
the Google pub/sub so as data is being
streamed in through this now I can go in
and capture the data so I also have this
terminal so what you see here is a
terminal where I can capture the data
that's coming in so the data that being
streamed through the point of sale
devices is being streamed here and
within data hub I can add a terminal
window to actually see what data is
being streamed so the idea here is not
to really read through that stream but
we're just showing you how you can also
look at the actual data being streamed
in
and we also have an integration with
track driver from GCP to analyze the
monitoring of this information so how
much data is being streamed in at
specific intervals of time so if I
switch to the pipeline primarily here
I'm looking at what data is being
streamed in and then where I'm being
able to capture that into Google
bigquery
so now that I have the data being
streamed in I'm looking at Google
bigquery and looking at the data that's
being streamed in real time here so I'm
just running a query to show that the
number of rows are increasing so it was
around 8,000 earlier and now it's at
16,000 840 so this is primarily showing
that I am streaming this data from
Google pub/sub built this pipeline using
data hub and then in the next step I'm
going to be consuming this as part of a
Hana calculation view where I consume
this Google bigquery as a virtual table
and then make that available through
ASAP Hana smarted access so this is
where I'm using the Google bigquery
table I'm consuming that as a virtual
table using that logical data
warehousing concept and then make that
available for my bi analysis through
Hana calculation views in the next step
I'm doing some visualization I'm not
going to talk too much about the vasila
visualization because once you've done
the heavy lifting in terms of building
that pipeline which is where the meat of
the work happens which is where a data
engineer comes in and has to do the
different part in terms of configuring
my different sources in this case being
Google pub/sub and then making that data
available through Google bigquery and
finally expose that into a Hana table if
you have time I can do the other demo we
have 24 minutes right so let me switch
to the other demo where I can show a few
more screens of SAPD the hub and its
capabilities
all right so what you see here is the
data hub cockpit this is kind of the UI
for a Administrator where he or she
comes in and sets up the landscape so in
terms of the landscape I want to create
different systems I want to set up these
zones where I can categorize the
different systems so I'm providing a
connection here to my Hana system or it
could be to my ERP system or a hadoop
system I have the options of setting up
the systems depending on the source
systems that I have to connect to so
here you see a list of the different
systems I've connected to and then as
next step I can go in there and I can
browse through the different data points
that we have so in in my case I'm going
to go through data discovery exercise so
here I have the option of browsing
through my hadoop connections so I can
browse through HDFS folder and I can
look at the different files in their
pathway files over C file CSV files or
if I want to connect through a GCP or
any cloud storage I have the same option
in this exercise I'm just going to go
through a Hana system and I'm going to
browse through a Hana view that I'm
going to then run through a data
profiling task so I have information
here for the sales order so now I'm in
the data discovery or data profiling
space where I'm looking at the data that
I have so this is just a sample data and
this is where the data wrangling part
kind of kicks in so you want to get
introduced to hate now I want to do a
data wrangling kind of exercise before
that I want to understand the spread of
the data
so I want to look at the profiling
information and the fact sheet where I
can see what are the different values of
the data what does the spread of data
say in terms of what are the distinct
values so here I go to the fact sheet
and I can look at the different data
points or have information about this
has around 1.9 million unique sales
information around 20,000 customers
5,000 products terms of the master data
for my customer and products who
purchase this specific
product and it I have the data for three
years depending on the data points that
you have are dependent on the source for
example if it is a park a file obviously
you'll have much larger data set and in
a lot of our customers they want to
store the cold data in Hadoop system or
a data Lake system so the profiling
tasks for a Hadoop system or even for a
cloud system can be enabled similar to
what you're seeing here from Hana table
now I enter into the pipeline modeler so
the idea here is as a data engineer or a
data modeler or even a data scientist
you want to understand the data a little
bit before you can really play around
with the data so if you are a data
scientist you're using the Jupiter
notebooks or ipython notebooks in our
case we provide this data hub tool where
you have UI enabled way of dragging and
dropping information and trying to build
your pipelines so here you're looking at
a pipeline where we've used the data
that we got from the sales order table
and we are running some predictive
algorithms in this case we're going to
be using Python initially and in the
next phase we are going to be using R so
we'll show you how you can very easily
modify your predictive algorithms to
suit whatever you're comfortable with so
if you are tensorflow customer you can
just rip and replace a Python algorithm
with it and the flow algorithm and you
can enable the prediction so we have two
tasks here one is training the algorithm
and the other one is the serving part
and now I'm showing you how we build the
training algorithm using Python so I'm
opening up my sequel generator which is
where I'm getting the data from my Hana
system so the sales order table that you
just saw I'm going to bring in that data
and I'm going to convert that to a CSV
format so that I can feed that to my
Python model so that it can take the
data and then do analysis on that Python
model so we leverage some of the open so
libraries like pandas and lifetime so
again this is I can bring in any
external algorithm I can make that
available as part of my pipeline and
leverage the insights that I get out of
that so what you're seeing here is this
is called a graph or a pipeline within
data hub and each of those blocks are
the operators so we deliver around 200
plus operators to do different tasks
whether that you want to anonymize the
data in slight you want to do data
cleansing you want to do geocoding
reverse geocoding you want to enable
location intelligence on top of that
audio as a partner want to build your
own operator we provide all those
capabilities as part of data hub and
extend that even to machine learning and
AI as well so I'm just showing some open
source libraries that I'm importing from
pandas this is the Python library that
we returned for doing the predictive
analysis based on the sales sales orders
data so just switching through the demo
so what I have here is when I execute
this I am training this model so there
is first the training phase which I'm
doing and then once I've trained it I'm
going to serve the model so that I can
apply this model on new data that's
coming in or real-time data that's
coming in to be able to get a prediction
out of that real-time data
so let me quickly move through this so
basically what you're seeing here is
right now I have the Train model or the
serving model so I've used the Python
serve model here and I'm going to be
loading the data that I got from my
trained ml model I'm going to feed that
through this prediction Python and then
get a prediction so based on the inputs
that you provide for this prediction
you'll be able to get a prediction from
that model saying depending on the
customer and they're buying pattern if I
provide the number of days there is a
high probability that the customer is
going to buy another similar product so
here I'm picking up the customer ID
customer information and the product and
then I specify the day and based on the
number of days it's going to tell me
what's the probability that the customer
might buy product so this is again based
on the historic information about what
this customers bought this certain level
of recommendation capabilities as well
so when I punch in fifty days there is
one point five one times probability
when I punch in 500 days there's a 14
times probability that the customer
might buy this product so now I switch
from using Python algorithm to our
algorithm so we'll show you how easy it
is
so we've already created a graph so what
we do is first we copy this pipeline so
I already have a pipeline so this is the
whole reusability part of how developer
can reuse pipelines that are already
existing in your repository so I'm just
going to call this with a different name
I'm going to call it train for R and
then I go in I remove this so I'm just
literally going to delete that operator
and I'm going to drag and drop our
operator so obviously depending on and
like you see
on the left side it could be a tensor
flow of operator as well so here I'm
looking at the code from our standpoint
so this is a custom code that have
returned for R and then I just have to
connect my operator to the input data
feed that I'm getting and then I'll be
ready to train this graph using the new
R operator
our code that I just inserted into this
pipeline so I just have to make some
changes in terms of what the model name
is I'll go through that it's a similar
exercise as we did in the previous time
now I'm running the train model once I
complete this in the next step I'm going
to bring in the sir model so I'm going
to do the same thing so here I have the
python-based sir model I'm just going to
save it as a different name and then
literally drop that operator add R
operator and then use that for serving
the serving this graph so that you can
see the prediction difference and this
is something that data scientists would
always want to do because they there's
always something new coming in from the
different libraries so you want to
ensure that you can get as close to the
prediction to real-time right so I'm
just going to drop that I'm bringing in
the our serve model and then I'm going
to connect to the model that I created
using my R train
and the same prediction now so I
switched from 50 days to find the days
and you see in the previous one it was
14 times probability now it's 17 times
probability so you as a data scientist
you have some tools that you can play
around with in terms of this is your
favorite algorithm so you can do some
kind of analysis based on that
so I just wanted to show life system so
that you guys don't think like we're
just showing you some recorded demo so
again what you're seeing here is the
data hub homepage so this is the latest
version of the homepage which will be
available for customers end of this week
I think so this is the new version so we
have multiple applications so what you
are seeing right now is the more a
modeler which is what I have here or the
data hub modeler which is the pipeline
modeler and we also introduced other
things like metadata explorers so one of
the big things that we are seeing from a
lot of customers and again there are
several startups that are trying to
solve this problem the capability to
provide metadata management data
cataloging lineage impact analysis
across the different disparate data
sources and again it's not just limited
to how my data in my scipy systems I can
do lineage no talking about lineage all
the way from your bi report whether it
is a tableau dashboard or ASAP analytics
cloud dashboard all the way to the s AP
ERP system so those are things that we
can do from a data hub standpoint so we
are bringing in multiple capabilities
into a single tool so that you don't
have to go look at different tools to do
different things and all these are
available as part of Google cloud
platform and we have customers that
Amogh is going to be talking about in
terms of the use cases so I'm going to
pause there and I'm going to pass it
back to I'm ok
yeah thank you Balaji I think one more
thing also our board member went like
Curt and Diane have also announced that
we are able to sprout in 30 minutes if
you want to try out
ACP data hub on Google cloud platform
using using kubernetes and super I'll
just walk you briefly through couple use
cases just starting with one of the
customers who has a parallel session
right now a tippy financial here is how
they are also bringing out the kind of
benefits they see their goal was to have
zero dissatisfied customers they have
seen a huge increase in efficiency and
for their operations and delivery by 30
to 40 percent this is where they were
able to bring out their data-driven
approach we have been discussing couple
use cases with them as well also they
are working with the Google cloud team
they are trying to set up a data science
lab in there they're having also on Prem
HANA and Hadoop kind of a setup and
multiple use cases including customer
satisfaction how can they enrich the the
customer experience or also try and
bring out more and more customer churn
scenarios so that way they are able to
predict what product from them it's
bringing out what impact another
customer of ours is also able to use now
machine learning as well as predictive
analysis we give a lot of operators as
you saw from the demos Balaji gave you I
think they're over 220 plus as we go on
we are embracing everything that's
available and you can include then a
seamless integration towards sa PBW for
Hana as well you can have different
zones set up one for data science one
towards data management or data
engineers and have that seamless flow
and orchestration of data as
you will of course you want to see
Balaji already demonstrated how once the
model is proven you can easily bring
that into production or industrialized
that model and then another nice story
of a customer we have seen all those
smart appliances and connected world and
so on here we saw a customer giving us a
challenge there were six million devices
generating 16 terabytes of data per day
they had a first challenge their data
science team they were paying top dollar
for that kind of data science team and
they ended up using four or five
different tools
now we shall out thousands of dollars
for these and their idea was to see that
whatever features are coming out from
that they wanted to get a good
production efficiency they saw the usage
of that they were able to bring all that
data in but there were a lot of issues
you know there were five different tools
there was a lot of manual coding there
was no automation possible and there was
no end-to-end visibility they did not
know where the data was stuck or whether
it was not running onto a good model
with ACP data of what we changed we
refined complete end-to-end process
using one single tool we were able to
give them a nice visual modeling
environment we also brought in
governance we understood their process
and then help them automate that from
one region they were able to scale out
into multiple regions as well and we
were completely helping them in the
end-to-end orchestration and refining
their data so they were not only able to
bring down that from the ten features
that were given out in this new
appliance whether only three of them
were used they pushed a campaign and out
of that came in use of four more but
then persistently they saw that in all
different regions three were not being
used and they stopped the production of
those because it was not being used at
the same time they also were matching or
matching that data with the enterprise
data in ACP all these kind of raw
streaming data came in together if your
mere pink
some dollars for this we want to see
that it is not lying around for three to
four months when the service vendor
comes and gave us service right so we
were able to bring that data mash it up
with the customer information with the
vendor information and based on the
error code they were able to proactively
reach out to the service vendor in that
area and said that please carry part ABC
and more than 85% of the times in one
single visit they were able to resolve
the issues and had a very loyal customer
another quick example is about how the
fitness tracker data is there most of us
are using wearable devices and we were
able to now stream data from there
across the globe we were able to bring
in the sales figures we were able to
bring in what type of for example a
jogging shoe or a running shoe was used
by that consumer and not only that but
when we refined all these we were able
to help them deliver insights we were
able to then bring this data towards an
analytics dashboard and bring out with
with a model that based on the pattern
or the jogging pattern of of the
consumer and the type of shoe they have
they were able to bring out you know
much more upsell opportunities more than
20% in some regions so that way they
were able to increase their sales as
well in the end very briefly you heard
also from our board member burn Troy cut
in the morning
here is how Aesop is trying to bring out
more how simplified data management can
be in the future together with a CP HANA
that is what is our ACP data management
suite data hub is one of the significant
components in that and as you have seen
already we are able to scale out into
our partners like Google Cloud and and
also others what we are also trying to
deliver now in terms of our strategy is
gear up all of you towards an
intelligent enterprise in their in the
digital play
form of course is driven through ACP
Hana and ACP data hub is then the core
of the data management where we are
wanting to help you in all the multi
cloud environments and have that
seamless flow of data manage and give
you a wonderful customer experience as
well and just a brief take away if you
will how ACP data hub is then gonna help
you bring in a kind of consolidated view
across all the sources of data how it is
going to help bring in intelligent
discovery as we move ahead we will be
able to help you also more and more with
improvised data quality and cleansing we
will be able to help you with kind of
enrichment of the data how we can have
distributed processing across this kind
of hyper scale architectures how we can
help you with kind of scalable data ops
management as you move into the cloud
you hold as well in the keynote in the
morning that is where they want to
automate more and more and last but not
the least also get optimal and compliant
data governance across the enterprise
even for the data that is now becoming
more and more relevant the unstructured
one how you can help get more grip over
that here are some of the resources
which are available for you please note
the links and of course you can reach
out to ACP as well through here and
we'll be happy to help you in that thank
you very much please do not forget to to
also give feedback on the app and we'll
open up the round for any questions now
thank you
[Music]